You know how when you're working on your computer, right?
You're totally focused right in the zone.
Oh yeah.
And suddenly this like giant flashing red pop-up
just blocks your entire screen.
Oh yeah, like a malware warning.
Yeah.
Or some incredibly loud intrusive ad for, I don't know,
something you'd never buy.
It just completely freezes everything else
you were trying to do.
Right, and you click the little X to close it.
Another one instantly pops up.
Exactly, another one pops up.
And then three more.
Yeah.
You're frantically hitting escape,
trying to force quit the application
because you know those windows don't belong there.
Yeah, they are actively hijacking your system.
Right, and you desperately just want your clean desktop back
so you can actually function.
It's awful, that feeling of helplessness is so visceral.
Yeah.
I mean, you are completely derailed, held hostage
by this process you didn't initiate,
and you just, you can't easily override it.
Yeah, and that desperate feeling
of your system being hijacked,
that actually brings us straight to the core
of today's deep dive.
We're looking at how the human brain
essentially generates its own malware.
So we have this highly concentrated medical study prep guide.
From Pass Ready Prep.
Yeah, from Pass Ready Prep,
put together by an instructor named Keek.
And it maps out this incredibly detailed
clinical landscape of OCD
and its family of related conditions.
It's a really fantastic resource.
It really is.
And our ultimate mission today for you, the listener,
is to understand the fascinating nuances
of these conditions, and crucially,
what Keek calls the treatment split.
Yes, the treatment split.
Because if there is one thing,
this source material just hammers home over and over,
it's that a one-size-fits-all approach
absolutely does not work
for these related, yet distinct disorders.
No, treating them all exactly the same way
is honestly a guaranteed recipe for failure.
Wow, really?
Yeah, I mean, we're gonna look closely
at not just the surface-level symptoms,
but the underlying mechanisms.
Because when you understand the specific architecture
of the cognitive loop a person is trapped in,
you quickly realize why these conditions
require fundamentally different behavioral interventions.
All right, let's unpack this.
Keek starts us off with the anchor of this entire family,
which is obsessive-compulsive disorder.
Right, classic OCD.
And the notes list out clinical codes like F42.2
because medical students obviously need those
for their exams.
Sure, for the test.
But we are gonna focus entirely on the mechanics today
because people use the term OCD
so casually in everyday life.
Oh, constantly.
Yeah, usually to describe someone who likes a tidy desk
or organizes their books by color.
Right, and using it casually like that
really does a massive disservice
to the reality of the actual diagnosis.
Yeah.
In a clinical setting, true OCD requires
two major distinct components,
obsessions, and compulsions.
Okay, so break those down for us.
So obsessions are those intrusive, unwanted thoughts
or urges or images that just drive
this intense, paralyzing anxiety.
That's the malicious pop-up on your screen.
Exactly, that is the pop-up.
And then the compulsions are the repetitive behaviors
or mental acts the person performs
in this desperate attempt to neutralize that anxiety.
So that is you frantically clicking the X
over and over to make the pop-up go away.
Spot on, and it's exhausting for the patient.
I bet.
And the Prick Guide lays out
a very specific threshold for this, right?
To actually meet the criteria,
these compulsions have to be seriously time-consuming.
Yes.
Geek & Notes, they have to take up more than an hour a day
and they must actively impair the person's life.
So we aren't talking about, you know,
double-checking the locks on your front door
once before you leave.
No, no, we are talking about checking them
50 times until your hands bleed, right?
Making you two hours late for work every single day.
Jeez.
That's entirely debilitating.
The brain's thread detection system
has essentially gone rogue.
Wow.
That's sounding a life or death alarm
for something that is objectively harmless.
Yeah.
But the key to understanding this condition
lies in a clinical term.
Kick highlights here, which is egotistonic.
Egotistonic, okay, this is where the computer analogy
really solidifies things for me.
Yeah.
Yeah, because egotistonic basically means
the person actively does not want
these thoughts or behaviors, right?
That's exactly.
They know it's a virus.
They hate the pop-ups.
They are completely distressed by the rituals
they feel forced to perform,
which leads directly into that diagnostic trap
Keek warns about.
The confusion with OCPD.
Right, confusing OCD with OCPD,
which is obsessive compulsive personality disorder.
What's fascinating here is the tragic irony
of that confusion, really.
How so?
Well, OCD is egotistonic.
The patient is trapped in a loop they despise.
They are fully aware that their fears are irrational,
yet they're just powerless
to stop the physiological panic.
Right, their body's betraying them.
Exactly.
But OCPD, on the other hand, is egotistonic.
Okay, so if OCD is the malicious malware pop-up
you're desperately trying to close,
OCPD is like a hyper rigid organizational software
that you actively installed yourself.
Yes.
You love it.
You think it's making your system run perfectly.
Right.
And frankly, you think everyone else in the office
should be forced to install it on their computers too.
That is a perfect way to conceptualize it.
The person with OCPD doesn't see their rigidity
as a problem at all.
To them, it's a feature, not a bug.
So they agree with the rigid structure.
Exactly.
They believe their way of doing things
is the objectively correct way.
There's no anxiety-driven ritual happening there.
It's just a deeply ingrained personality trait.
Got it.
But with true OCD, the intrusive obsessions
and the compulsions are an unwanted hijacking.
And because it's a hijacking
driven by severe acute anxiety,
the first line treatment has to be highly specific.
Right, and the notes detail that the treatment
is cognitive behavioral therapy,
but it has to be built on this specific framework
called ERP, right?
Yes, exposure and response prevention.
And this is often paired with SSRI medications.
Which are surprisingly used at much higher doses
than you typically prescribe
for standard depression, actually.
Oh, really?
That's interesting.
But okay, looking at ERP,
I mean, if someone is absolutely terrified
of a specific trigger, say, I don't know, contamination,
forcing them to confront it, sounds honestly like torture.
It sounds incredibly harsh, yes.
Because you are exposing them to the fear
but preventing the neutralizing response.
Exactly.
You are intentionally triggering the obsession
while actively blocking the compulsion.
Wow.
So if their obsession is contamination
and their compulsion is washing their hands raw,
ERP involves having them touch a slightly dirty surface
and then actively preventing them from washing their hands.
So you're literally forcing them to sit
with the pop-up flashing on the screen,
the alarms blaring in their head
without letting them hit the escape key.
Yes.
How does that not just traumatize the patient even further?
It's a great question.
It relies on a biological process called habituation.
Habituation, okay.
See, the human nervous system cannot sustain a state
of maximum panic indefinitely.
It is biologically impossible.
Right, you just pass out eventually.
Exactly, you'd run out of adrenaline.
When a person with OCD performs a compulsion,
they artificially cut off the anxiety curve
before it can naturally peak and decline on its own.
Ah.
They essentially teach their brain,
hey, the only reason I survived that panic
is because I washed my hands.
Oh, wow.
So with ERP, you force them to ride that wave of anxiety
all the way up and more importantly, all the way down.
So they learn that the anxiety
will eventually subside on its own.
They physically experience it subsiding.
You break the cycle by proving to the brain
that the neutralizing behavior isn't the only way out.
The false link is severed.
The first link between the ritual and survival
is completely severed.
Man, that's powerful.
Okay, so we've just mapped out how the brain
gets trapped in this broad internal threat loop
with classic OCD.
Right.
But what happens when that exact same life
or death intensity gets projected externally,
like specifically onto the mirror?
Ah, yeah.
Because that brings us to body dysmorphic disorder,
or BDD.
And that shift from internal scenarios
to external form is profound.
Yeah, F45.22 in the notes.
Right.
BDD is defined as a preoccupation
with the perceived flaw in one's physical appearance.
But crucially, this flaw is completely invisible to others.
Or it appears so slight
that an outside observer wouldn't even notice it, right?
It's like looking into a carnival funhouse mirror.
But the person is absolutely convinced
that the distorted reflection is reality.
Yes.
And just like OCD,
it comes with a set of repetitive behaviors.
Right, the sourceless, endless mirror checking,
excessive grooming,
constantly comparing themselves to strangers,
and just relentless reassurance seeking.
Because the focus is entirely
on this perceived physical defect.
And the treatment aligns pretty closely with OCD.
First line is CBT plus an SSRI.
Okay, so similar toolset.
Yes.
But Keek includes two massive clinical warnings here
that fundamentally reframe
how we have to view this disorder.
Okay, what's the first one?
The first is that the suicide risk
associated with BDD is exceptionally high.
Wow.
Yeah, that really strips away any casual misunderstanding
that this disorder is just vanity or narcissism.
Absolutely, it's not vanity at all.
It's a severe life-threatening distortion of reality
where the person feels literally trapped
inside a monstrous version of themselves.
That is heartbreaking.
The distress is overwhelming
because you cannot escape your own physical form.
Right.
If your trigger is a dirty doorknob,
you can just walk away from the door.
Right.
If your trigger is your own face,
there is no escape.
You take it everywhere.
And that leads to the second major
clinical warning Keek notes.
Cosmetic procedures do not fix body dysmorphic disorder.
Okay, here's where it gets really interesting.
Because the study guide explicitly states
that if a patient with BDD undergoes plastic surgery
to fix the perceived flaw,
the preoccupation simply relocates.
It just moves.
It's like a nightmarish game of whack-a-mole.
That's exactly what it is.
Like someone agonizes over their nose for a decade.
They get surgery.
The nose is technically fixed by the surgeon,
but within days that intense debilitating anxiety
just pops up on their chin or their ears or their jawline.
Because you cannot use a surgical scalpel
to treat a cognitive loop.
Wow, put that on a T-shirt.
Seriously though,
the root issue is entirely
in the brain's processing centers, right?
It's not in the cartilage or the tissue of the body.
Altering the physical tissue does absolutely nothing
to rewire the neural pathways
that are actively generating the obsession.
That makes total sense.
And before we leave BDD,
Keek mentions a very specific diagnostic boundary
that I think is really important.
Of the eating disorder distinction.
Yeah.
The notes say if a patient's preoccupation
is focused strictly on their overall weight and body shape,
clinicians are instructed not to diagnose BDD.
Right, because that shifts the diagnostic path entirely
into the eating disorder category.
Like anorexia or bulimia.
Exactly.
The clinician has to be incredibly precise
about the exact nature of the perceived flaw
because miscategorizing it
could lead to the entirely wrong treatment protocol.
Got it.
Okay, let's follow that idea
of externalizing the anxiety a bit further.
We've gone from projecting onto the physical body
to projecting onto physical objects.
Ah, yes.
Which brings us to hoarding disorder.
Right.
The core definition here is a persistent difficulty
parting with possessions.
And the critical phrase Keek emphasizes
for clinicians to remember
is completely regardless of their actual value.
Regardless of actual value.
So it's the brain assigning massive vital importance
to things that are objectively valueless.
Yes.
We are talking about like stacks of old newspapers,
broken electronics, junk mail flyers from five years ago.
Exactly.
And the mechanism driving this
is a deeply felt need to save these items
and severe acute distress
at the mere thought of discarding them.
And the clinical result is just devastating, right?
The clutter completely fills and disables living spaces.
It's tragic.
The kitchen can no longer be used for cooking.
The bathtub is filled to the ceiling with doxxas
so they can't bathe.
The bed can't be slept in.
The possessions literally colonize the person's environment
until the home just ceases to function as a home.
That's a great way to put it.
They colonize the space.
Now Keek points out a major recent shift
in the medical field regarding hoarding.
Yes, a very important shift.
It's now its own distinct diagnosis.
It is no longer considered just a subset
or like a flavor of OCD.
But looking at the mechanics, I have a question.
True.
If someone is hoarding, say, broken toasters,
how is their distress overthrowing one away
different from a standard OCD compulsion?
Aren't they just trying to prevent a disaster
like in classic OCD?
It's a really good distinction to make.
The difference lies in where the value
and the fear are actually anchored.
Okay, what do you mean?
Well, in classic OCD, the compulsion is performed
to neutralize a specific terrifying intrusive thought
that is often completely unrelated to the object itself.
Okay, give me an example.
So if I don't tap this doorknob three times,
my family will die in a car crash.
Oh, right.
The doorknob has literally nothing to do
with the car crash.
It's just a magical thinking ritual.
Precisely, it's magical thinking.
But in hoarding, the distress is intrinsically tied
to the physical object itself.
The anxiety is about the loss of the item,
the perceived waste of throwing it away,
or, and this is a big one,
the terrifying belief that throwing away an old receipt
means permanently losing the memory
associated with that day.
Wow.
The cognitive error is in how the brain
calculates utility and emotional attachment.
So they essentially anthropomorphize the objects.
The junk mail isn't just paper.
It feels like an extension of their own identity
or their history.
Which is why Keek notes that hoarding
requires specialized CBT.
Standard exposure and response prevention
isn't sufficient here.
Because it's not a magical thinking loop.
Right, you can't just expose them to an empty room
and expect habituation to happen.
That wouldn't work?
No, you have to actively rebuild
their decision-making skills.
You have to rebuild their categorization abilities
and dismantle the very specific cognitive distortions
they hold regarding the meaning of possessions.
That reinforces the recurring theme perfectly.
The one-size-fits-all treatment approach
just utterly fails.
It does?
You really have to address the specific architecture
of the delusion.
Which brings us to the final two conditions
Keek covers in this guide.
The body-focused, repetitive behaviors.
Right, we are moving entirely away
from complex cognitive anxieties
like agonizing over perceived facial flaws
or saving junk mail to preserve a memory.
You're leaving the cognitive realm.
And entering the territory of pure,
raw, physical habit loops.
Yes, so we have trichotillomania,
which is recurrent hair pulling
leading to noticeable hair loss.
And we have excordiation disorder,
which is recurrent skin picking
resulting in actual skin lesions.
The detail in the notes that really stuck with me here
is the phrase, with repeated attempts to stop.
It is written right there in the diagnostic criteria
for both of these conditions.
And that detail alone, I mean,
it reveals how frustrating and isolating this must be.
It really does.
The person is trying over and over again
to stop pulling their eyebrows
or picking their skin
and they physically cannot stop themselves.
It's vital to recognize
that these are not deliberate acts of self-harm.
That's a huge misconception.
Right, they aren't doing it to hurt themselves.
No, they're deeply ingrained, almost automatic urges.
They often happen in this sort of trance-like state
when the person is bored
or reading a book or stressed.
And because these are automatic physical habits
rather than anxiety-driven rituals,
we see the most radical shift in the treatment protocol.
Yeah, the first line treatment here
is habit reversal training or HRT.
Which is a purely behavioral approach.
Right, and KICK specifically underlines
that this is not exposure therapy.
No, definitely not.
So if there's no fear, just a physical urge,
does that mean you can't use ERP?
I mean, you obviously can't expose someone
to their own hair to trigger a fear response.
So do you just have to physically block their hands
from reaching their head?
This raises an important question
and it goes right to the heart
of understanding these mechanisms.
You aren't just blocking the hands,
you are consciously rerouting the motor pathway.
As we established earlier,
exposure therapy is for confronting a fear.
Right, the contamination fear.
But with trichotillomania or excoriation,
there is no terrifying intrusive thought.
There is no malware pop-up warning of impending doom.
Right, so what is it?
It's just an itch in the brain.
Basically, yes.
It's a pure motor urge, a physical habit loop.
So exposing them to the trigger does absolutely nothing.
Okay, so how does habit reversal training
actually work then?
It involves bringing acute conscious awareness
to a process that has become totally subconscious.
The patient learns to recognize the exact micro-moment
their hand begins to move toward their scalp
or their arm.
But okay, so once they catch that movement in real time.
They are trained to immediately perform
a physically incompatible response.
A physically incompatible response.
Yes, for example,
the moment you feel the urge to pull your hair,
you are trained to firmly clench your fists
and press them down against your thighs.
Or like grip the arms of your chair
and just hold that incompatible posture
until the urge naturally passes.
Oh wow, so you are literally hacking
the physical motor pathway.
Because by clenching your fists,
you physically cannot pull your hair.
You replace the destructive habit
with a neutral physical action.
Exactly, you are rewriting the neurological habit loop
through physical repetition,
entirely bypassing the cognitive fear centers
that ERP targets.
So what does this all mean?
Let's bring all these individual pieces together
for the grand synthesis here.
Okay.
We've explored this entire family of disorders
and we've seen how wildly the interventions must vary
based on the specific nature of the loop.
If we connect this to the bigger picture,
you really have to praise the structure
of this study material.
Yeah, KICK did a great job.
Because by rigorously categorizing
the exact nature of the symptom,
the solution just naturally reveals itself.
Right.
Classic OCD driven by intrusive fears
and unwanted ego-distonic compulsions
requires exposure and response prevention
to break the fear cycle.
Right, sitting with the anxiety until it habituates.
Then we have body dysmorphic disorder
where someone is trapped in a perceived external flaw
that surgery cannot cure.
Right, the whack-a-mole effect.
And that gets CBT and SSRIs
to address the cognitive distortion of self-image.
Then there's hoarding disorder,
rooted in an inability to discard items
regardless of value.
That requires specialized CBT
focused on dismantling the emotional attachments
and actively rebuilding basic sorting skills.
And finally, the body-focused repetitive behavior,
so the hair pulling and skin picking,
they get habit reversal training,
no exposure therapy,
just hacking the motor pathways with incompatible responses.
Whether you are a medical student cramming for an exam
or just someone trying to understand a loved one
who is struggling with these invisible battles,
the biggest takeaway is recognizing the exact nature
of the behavioral loop before you try to intervene.
You have to.
You absolutely have to know
what kind of software you're dealing with
before you start trying to rewrite the code.
Perfectly said.
Approaching a pure physical habit loop
with a cognitive fear treatment is like,
well, it's like bringing a wrench
to fix a software glitch.
It's the wrong tool,
and it will only cause more frustration
for a patient who is already suffering immensely.
Well, that wraps up our time today.
Thank you for joining us on this deep dive
into the fascinating complex world of OCD
and its family of related conditions.
It's been great.
We've gone from the overwhelming malware popups
of classic obsessions
to the deeply ingrained physical loops
of body-focused habits.
It is a profound reminder
of how intricate the human mind truly is
and how precise the science of healing must be
to navigate all that complexity.
Absolutely.
And as we leave you today,
we want to offer a final lingering thought.
We spent this entire deep dive
exploring ego-dystonic behaviors,
actions people perform that they actively hate doing
driven by either deep cognitive fears
or automatic physical urges.
So consider this,
if an unwanted action can completely hijack
a person's daily life without their consent,
at what point does a simple, quirky daily routine
cross that invisible line into a compulsion?
Ooh, that's a good question.
Next time you catch yourself doing something repetitive,
whether it's obsessively refreshing
your phone notifications,
chewing your lip while reading,
or arranging the pens on your desk
until they are perfectly parallel,
ask yourself, who is really in the driver's seat?
Is it you or is it the pop-up?
Keep learning and we'll catch you on the next deep dive.